hello there citizens of the reject
Nation Greg here today I'm going to do a
movie reaction for the film inside out
first things first please go ahead leave
a like doesn't take too much effort on
your end but it sure helps us out a lot
so thank you for doing that that's very
appreciated secondly yeah I'm a little
bit familiar with inside out I've heard
thematically what it deals with it's
always sounded very interesting to me
and here's the truth I I explained this
in a trailer reaction not long ago but
I'll do a quick like 10 second recap of
it and I'm gonna watch what I'm gonna
say just because YouTube's
hypersensitive here I rented this
probably in like 2015 and I fell asleep
about like 10 minutes in don't remember
those 10 minutes not because the movie
was boring but because I ate a special
dessert that uh 2015 Greg was taking
quite a bit of at the time and I knocked
out really fast so yeah never ended up
watching the movie and I had to return
to film the next day I've heard of this
movie throughout the years I've
constantly nodded my head in
conversation with people like it's kind
of look inside out I'm like yeah yeah
yeah and in my head I'm like what I know
of inside out but guys I'm here to do it
properly this time I'm ready to focus
and absorb this film also uh full
interaction watch along as we sync up
with your own copy of inside out I'm
watching this in Disney Plus available
for super sexy Rejects at our patreon
page I want to say once again thank you
to all who have joined our patreon thank
you to all who support us there because
you guys have been astronomically
beneficial for us and at times just of
massive savior in our lives so thank you
anywho let's finally watch this
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
and there she is so cute aren't you a
little bundle of joy
[Music]
memories it was amazing just Riley and
me
forever
for 33 seconds
[Music]
I'm sadness oh hello I I'm Joy can I
just if you could I just want to fix
that thanks and that was just the
beginning
oh there's so many so many emotions okay
looks like you got this very good
that's fear he's really good at keeping
Riley safe see easy huh oh we're good
we're good thank you thank you very much
and we're back
this is disgust she basically keeps
Riley from being poisoned physically and
socially that is not brightly colored or
shaped like a dinosaur it's broccoli
Riley if you don't eat your dinner
you're not gonna get any dessert wait
did he just say we couldn't have dessert
that's anger
no dessert oh sure we'll eat our dinner
right after you eat fish
tears are coming yep well she
[Music]
there's no place for her to go so she's
good we're good it's all great oh joy
can't exist without sadness to really
understand Joy but the really important
ones are over here I don't want to get
too technical but these are called core
memories
yes like when she first scored a goal
that was so amazing
damn I was psychologically deep is this
gonna get and each core memory Powers a
different aspect of Riley's personality
like hockey Island goofball island is my
personal favorite
come back here you little monkey
we love our girl and she's got great
friends and a great house things
couldn't be better after all Riley's 11
now
what could happen
dramatic memories we're getting close I
can feel it
there it is here's our new house
oh it'll get better we're supposed to
live here I'm telling you it smells like
something died in here can you die from
moving guys you're overreacting nobody
is done a dead mouse oh no all through
the drive Dad talked about how cool our
new room is let's go check it out it's
gonna be great yes yes yes yes yes no no
no no no no
well guess what the moving van won't be
here until Thursday you're kidding God
[Music]
she's closing in Hey Oh no you're not
coming behind you watch out watch out
I wonder what the actual plot of the
movie is
or is it just an exploration of Riley's
mind the investor is supposed to show up
on Thursday not today I gotta go it's
okay we get it see you sweetie dad just
left us oh he doesn't love us anymore
that's sad
you know what I realized Riley hasn't
had much remember
hey I saw a pizza place down the street
maybe we could try that pizza sounds
delicious yes
Pizza is always a joyful emotion what
the heck is that we're disgusting
broccoli I like that time with the
dinosaur that was pretty funny
[Music]
wait what what happened
she did something to the memory what did
you do sadness thinking of her dad
making her sat
wait what what happened
oh no she's not finding the joy and the
things she once found joy in anymore
she's growing up why are you
King
really the opposite of what we're going
for here crying helps me slow down and
obsess over the weight of life's
problems you know crying can actually be
very emotionally beneficial for you
long-term memory data selection via
Channel subgrouping see fun already oh
you lucky dog you're reading these cool
things I gotta go work life is so unfair
oh
Joy just keeps pushing away the sadness
a moving van
Tuesday can you believe it where's Dad
on the phone this new Venture is keep
ing oh no she's feeling neglected I
guess all I really want to say is
thank you huh you know through all this
confusion well you've stayed our happy
girl
your dad's under a lot of pressure but
if you and I can keep smiling it would
be a big help
we can do that for him but
would that deny Riley her own emotions I
have a feeling this movie's gonna break
me
this is surprisingly mature looks like
we're going into REM I've got dream Duty
so I'll take care of sending these great
day today guys I wish Joy would get to
work on my dreams oh this is it a new
place
somebody order a broccoli Pizza ah gross
I not supposed to do this but
we are not going to end the day like
this no
Joy here
your Nevada is all wrong Joy
oh that's beautiful what are you doing
in there perfect this is the circle of
sadness your job is to make sure that
all the sadness stays inside of it oh no
did you did building a wall around the
sadness
all the sadness stays in the circle
[Laughter]
okay everybody we have a new student in
class today are you kidding me out of
the gate the anxiety
my name is Riley Anderson I'm from
Minnesota and now I live here how about
Minnesota can you tell us something
about it Well you certainly get a lot
more snow than we do
she's okay
[Laughter]
pretty much everyone in my family skates
it's kind of a family tradition we go
out on the lake almost every weekend
oh it's turning sad again what
hagging stuff oh no Riley
[Music]
but everything's different now
since we moved oh Riley this is so sad
it's a core memory but it's blue oh
God
no that's a core me
[Music]
whoa what's happening
oh
thank you Riley I know it can be tough
moving to a new oh no she's shutting off
her emotions
no personality islands and no you're
headquarters without you Riley can't be
happy we gotta get you back up there oh
almost must hurt Riley to feel right now
fascinating empathetic experience right
here I found a junior hockey league
right here in San Francisco
here you you pretend to be Joy want to
be great to be back out on the ice
oh yeah that sounds fantastic
yikes the hone
did you guys pick up on that
what should we do we're gonna find out
what's happening but we'll need support
signal the husband
oh that's clever
that's really cool
oh she's looking at us uh what did she
say oh oh sorry sir no one was looking
signal him again
ah so Riley how was school
time for this we gave up that Brazilian
helicopter pilot
[Laughter]
school was great all right Riley is
everything okay tone Riley I do not like
this new attitude oh I'll show you
attitude no no no no stay happy oh no
that's your problem just leave me alone
sir reporting high levels of sass take
it to Defcon 2. you heard that gentleman
Defcon 2. yay I don't know where this
disrespectful attitude came from you
want a piece of this pops come and get
it yeah well look here it comes prepare
the foot ready to launch on your command
sir
[Music]
that's it go to your room
now uh put us down the foot is down
good job gentlemen that could have been
a disaster well that was a disaster
[Music]
Escape into those memories things got a
little out of hand downstairs
you want to talk about it come on
where's my happy girl
oh he's trying to start up goofball
this is so clever all her dominating
emotions are there this is so
fascinating I'm like so fascinated by
this
[Music]
oh goofball Island
that means she can lose friendship in
hockey and honesty and family you can
fix this right Joy I uh
try
oh we'll never make no no no no no no no
no don't obsess him
don't don't touch remember if you touch
them they stay sad oh sorry I I won't
[Music]
what happened with the playoffs we won
the first game bushes we might actually
go to the finals this year oh and we've
got this new girl on the team she's so
cool uh she did not speak oh new girl
Meg has a new friend already place no
need for Riley the newspaper is ready I
gotta go what I gotta go
go
go
[Music]
Island no
I love that one and now it's gone
goodbye friendship hello loneliness
Riley's imaginary friend and I'm Joy
they join well what the heck you doing
out here oh without you anyone ever be
happy we can't have that we got to get
you back uh I'll tell you what follow me
oh thank you what a great imaginary
friend you are
taking the train
[Music]
train oh good try this is abstract
thought what's wrong with that I'm not
missing that train Bing Bong knows what
he's doing he's part dolphin they're
very smart well I guess
this can be dangerous yes I like how
illustrative like the animation is yet
there's something that's they keep it
simple but not too bombastic it's
the right balance to strike for this
could have easily been just like Gonzo
Madness if they wanted it to be
I'm gonna turn it on for a minute and
burn out the gunk
no they turned it on ah never seen this
before Oh God okay never mind I guess
the thing I was saying they might do
what they're doing
abstracting there are four stages this
is the first non-objective fragmentation
oh God
the train
oh no we're not figurative
wait we're two-dimensional fall on your
face oh
sadness you figured it out
[Music]
trophy Town medals ribbons everyone's a
winner all the dreams and there's always
something new like
who the heck is that imaginary boyfriend
I would die for Riley
luck isn't gonna help us now if she
tries to use hockey Island it's going
down which is why I've recalled every
hockey memory I can think of one of
these has got to work in place of the
Corn memory she's about to play hurry
way to go fear
I'm rejecting it all
foreign
[Applause]
box box
Riley can't be done with me no that's so
sad it's gone forever sadness don't make
him feel worse sorry it's all I had left
of Riley
he can confide in sadness
we were best friends
yeah it's sad
there's a comfort to be had in sadness
when you align yourself to just feel it
this is this is a touching movie oh
nothing just the best idea ever what all
the good core memories were made in
Minnesota Air go we go back to Minnesota
oh no let's sleep on it because hey I'm
sure Jolly fun-filled times are just
around the corner
oh man she becomes super depressed
we're all on break
yeah the train of thought doesn't run
while she's asleep it's really not she
wakes up sometimes when she has a scary
dream we could scare her scare her no no
she's been through enough already we're
gonna make her so happy she'll wake up
with exhilaration
then that's never happened before
[Music]
I mean this is pretty scary
this is not working
[Music]
oh
you are ruining this dream you're
scaring her look it's working
oh damn sadness you've been pulling this
off you might know Riley better than Joy
I'm bingo
what is this place the subconscious
subconscious yeah hey you oh you got us
get back in there no escapement
no escaping
what is going
[Music]
handy wrap
it's a trail
thank you
very clowns huh
God it's so loud
we still have to wake up Riley but how
[Music]
scare her with jingles
follow us
this cannot be good for Riley's brain
but it is just her subconscious she's
dreaming
[Music]
man sadness has been holding it down
[Music]
so how are we gonna get to Minnesota
from here we're taking the bus Network
there's a bus leaving tomorrow no this
is terrible where would you stay Riley
you're not thinking this through
uh-huh
honesty Island
guys oh my God you gotta be kidding me
emotions at least for Salvage we have no
core memories you want Riley to be happy
let's get back to Minnesota and make
more if we hurry we can still stop her
family Island let's go
oh you know what the sad part is like
Riley just needs a a moment to be
vulnerable you know just to take an
opportunity to be sad and express that
have a great day sweetheart see you
after school monkey we love you
[Music]
haha what a fascinating illustration of
the mind if you get in here
oh that is messed up oh what a bunch of
[ __ ] Joy
[Music]
this music's freaking effective damn
it's that phrase out here for years of
like if you keep Chan chanting into the
garden there's no ways there's no ways
there's no weeds the weeds will overtake
the garden
[Music]
it is very possible to block
your emotions by trying to
like just do positive affirmations and
[ __ ] but
can't build the house on the sand it'll
sink
eventually
remember
oh she used to stick her tongue out when
she was coloring
interesting Joy's experiencing the
sadness
[Music]
interesting She's Like Coming to Terms
of reality
[Music]
laughs
ah there is a joyful memory there
that's that's really well done
I came to help because of sadness
we have to get back up there Joy kid
existed that satisfaction
s
[Music]
don't give up persistence persistence
come on
[Music]
[Music]
huh
we did it
that was great that's what her imaginary
friend wouldn't do geez
[Music]
I'll try Bing Bong like totally plays
with like
whatever [ __ ] childhood feelings you
have you know
sadness come on sadness where are you
okay if I were sadness where would I be
oh everything is awful
and you have to drag me around why touch
all the
[Music]
oh no it's Mom again what do we do
[Laughter]
it
[Music]
guys we can't make Riley feel anything
it's completely shut off
[Music]
wow
[Music]
now
[Music]
wow
[Music]
that worked well what would you do if
you're so smart
I tell you but you're too dumb to
understand oh my God
it's up to you me sadness Riley needs
you
that's
really sweet
what a fascinating lesson
[Music]
wait stop
how would you know how to get back
worried sick where have you been it's so
late
okay
that is fine
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
and my hockey team I want to go home
please don't be mad
oh
I miss Minnesota too
I miss the woods and we took hikes
come here
let's please don't be bad
[Music]
you did the sadness
it's beautiful man that's beautiful
[Music]
everything's restored God this is not
just won't stop being washed the shirt
I'm not missing one go [ __ ]
ers
[Music]
she loves the face painting I told you
it was a great idea
idea he's had in a while he's a really
good guy
just in case
[Music]
[Laughter]
we've been through a lot lately that's
for sure but we still love our girl she
has great new friends a great new house
things couldn't be better after all
Riley's 12 now
what could happen
[Laughter]
that was wonderful
that was absolutely wonderful
let's see what's in these credits since
the images are moving
[Applause]
yay
what
a little very accurate
[Laughter]
yes very true I love that let's talk
about it ah yes okay just gotta get a
good stretch in here yeah that was very
moving that was very very touching I
love the hell out of it guys that was an
amazing film
um
it's one of those movies where like the
messages and themes are
the centerpiece of the film and they are
like just driving the entire narrative
forward you know and it's crazy to they
can make something that feels high
stakes out of something that is not it's
like because we'll make something feel
high stakes in a film is why is is is
how how it could feel like life or death
for the main character pretty much like
you know the circumstances themselves
are not like that high stakes but when
you go to the recesses of the mining you
see the emotional turmoil and the
challenges that Riley is going through
uh that that makes it feel like I stick
so it's pretty crazy how they they put
this picture together I just was
watching it so fascinated by
by the whole construction because it has
a really like nicely woven message like
with with the most obvious one
being that being you know sadness is
okay and that it's okay to feel sad I
just repeated it myself I just repeated
that but yeah being sad is okay and that
there's
something meaningful to it and and that
the main thing that you have to learn to
to do in life
is to be honest with yourself and with
your emotions that and that like really
emotions
it's not really that emotions are good
or bad and I think you know and
depending on what part of the world you
live in
um but at least in the the sections of
the world I live in within Western
societal culture it often can be the
case of you know that there's a much
higher emphasis put on you know
obviously positive thinking is great
there's a lot of power and positive
thinking there's a lot of power in you
know good thoughts and stuff but that's
like what I just said right there was
the thing that I ought to not be saying
is because we often have a habit of
labeling our emotions as good or bad
when
emotions are just emotions and we ought
to be more accepting of just how we feel
and be okay with accepting how we feel
because that's how we move on that's how
we move forward you know uh that was one
of my earliest lessons I ever as someone
who's been in therapy for like a decade
at this point one of the close to a
decade one of the earliest lessons I
ever got because you know I was someone
who who got very much into
of personal development like a little
over a decade ago and who had a very
much like toxic depressive mindset at
least that's how I Associated and yeah
it was I was just a very manic person
and uh I was really really I felt like I
was really personally volatile and angry
all the time and uh just depressed like
constantly for most of my life
and when I began to understand where
they might come from you know in between
that time of understanding what I would
do with like personal development I you
know you would hear so much about
positive thinking and you know I was I
was around for the time when something
like the secret the law of attraction
was was brought into the Forefront and
especially being I know it exceeds far
past Los Angeles but being out in La
that was so such a dominant subject and
and and one thing that I think when you
think about like law of attraction or or
the power of like positive thinking like
you attract what you think about it's
not
it's not really like every emotion first
comes from thought sure and I think the
power of like attracting what you think
about it's really you attract what you
feel
and a lot of the times you know it we
there's there's way I I damn one of
those people who believes in the gray
side of it all like yeah like there's
there's power and powers of thinking
there's power and and reminding yourself
of what to really be grateful for
and
a lot of the time though you know some
people and I was exceptionally guilty of
this like life was not changing for me
because I would just try to reject I
would just reject it would be so hard to
face the things that I felt personally
traumatized by
by just trying to pile like I got this
like [ __ ] toxicity and baggage and I
was trying to pile positivity on top of
there but that doesn't make for a good
foundation and I feel like that's what
the message of this movie really is more
about more than just going it's okay to
be sad which is a great message uh to
convey like it's so it's okay to cry
it's so it's okay to show your emotions
it's okay to show how you really feel
and a big part in you know
moving past something it is first
accepting how you feel like it's it's
one thing to
be with your emotions of when you're sad
it's another thing to you know to get
lost in it and to become and dwell in it
so much to the point where yeah you are
just in a a void that that's the heart
that's the part where you don't want to
get two down there two down that rabbit
hole you know like life is just a
struggle for balance all the time and
that's just what I believe is that you
don't want to go too far down that hole
uh but at the same time there's that
that other side where it is okay to feel
how you feel and not reject it because
that's the only way you move on you know
grief has been such a prevalent Topic in
my life
and what a lot of people
often uh I think a hover between is the
first and fifth stage of what at one
time one of my I've had a couple of
therapists in my life and one my first
therapist what she pointed out to me was
was that because in grief there's like
five stages there's denial uh anger and
blame depression
a denial anger blame
um bargaining and depression and then
the last one being acceptance
and it's not like and what she pointed
out to me was that those first four
stages are all kind of
intertwined those first four of
they're all sort of like its own form of
shock and denial like those emotions
that are coming through are all sort of
its own form and then I think this movie
represents that really well because you
know as a as a child like with this
Riley character is dealing with of
feeling hurt and not having a decision
in the matter
and feeling like she has to put on a
happy face you know because Dad's going
through a hard time this is tough for
them but yeah I gotta be all smiles
that's what they expect from me and I
so as so anyway like that's as she's
dealing with like she's grieving over a
situation because that can be a
traumatizing experience for someone
where they are uprooting their whole
Foundation their whole base their whole
life
and having to start a new one and they
got to mourn the the life they're
leaving behind
so so I think that you know when you're
thinking about that in association with
grief because that's what she is doing
is grieving
she's experiencing those emotions you
know from from those stages of grief and
then the the part that you have to get
to is acceptance right is
acceptance doesn't mean I'm over it
necessarily like this acceptance just
means I I yeah I can deal with the
reality of it now and I can I can move
forward
but the thing about getting to
acceptance is you have to first feel all
your emotions and be honest with
yourself like whenever I'm around anyone
with loss I always say like the most
important thing you do right now is be
honest with yourself even if it's like I
don't want to feel right now or I I just
really can't deal with this be honest
with yourself when you can't do that so
that's what I loved about it was this in
in a day and age where it's like
I don't feel like we're
there's so much emphasis like if you go
on social media about
a one Niche area of of positive thinking
which is not a bad thing all obviously
it's positive a positive thinking where
this isn't more of an encouragement to
be honest with yourself and a lot of the
time when you do that that can naturally
pave the way for you to feel a more
sincere genuine way of feeling happiness
that these emotions can coexist that
they don't have to necessarily cancel
out one one another and they can help
support each other and that's what makes
us human
um
there's a book I read it's actually not
a religious book despite what the title
might make you think I'm not like I'm
certainly not a religious person
this book was called conversations with
God and one of the things that book
really uh emphasized on is life is about
experience and you can't really have
one emotion without the other like in
order to truly understand one emotion
you have to experience the other so
that's why like early on in the movie I
was like Joy you can't exist Joy cannot
really exist without really
understanding what sadness is like
because that's what really helps us to
understand Joy is when we completely
understand the opposite and it's like
that with a wide variety of emotions
you know so I think with what this movie
did and talking so much thematically and
like the movies thematically on display
the whole time and that's why I loved it
because it was that that was The
Narrative of the of the film like when
everything is collapsing and then when
she like shut when Riley shuts herself
off when it becomes too too painful to
deal with it she's just left
in the stages of fear and anger and
and like disgust just these three
emotions and this is all because like to
deal with joy like can't feel Joy and
dealing with sadness is too hard so
they're just pushed down to the recesses
of her mind and this is all that she has
to work with on the Forefront
if there was something that felt very
real and and truthful in that depiction
uh I thought it was it was great because
like the characters the emotions are
written so well like it I felt like I
kind of craved a little bit more out of
the disgust character I think that's one
Mindy calling was playing I kind of
creeped a little bit more out of her in
terms of just the writing because yeah
she was like the least standout of the
personalities to me
what and I think there might that might
have something to do with the fact that
you know the other emotions are more
easier to pinpoint where disgust seems
like there's a specific like oh this is
disgusting the other emotions can
present a little bit more of a range
like Fear Can represent you know I once
heard that every emotion comes down to
love or fear and if you take any emotion
that kind of belonged to one of those
categories but if you're gonna break it
down within the rules of this movie of
the mind you know like fear was able to
show you the anxiety parts of it all and
those kind of emotions and uh anger
would have some of those bargaining
stages you know the blame stages that I
thought were great
and uh yeah sadness and joy learning
from one another I guess those are like
the two Primal emotions for for
depicting this and I think the the voice
acting work by Phyllis Smith from the
office amazing work it's brought such
sweetness to the role
Joy Amy Poehler what I loved was
bringing the right ounce of
what I thought was great about her voice
over work and obviously this isn't the
writing is that she
it is kind of that thing I was talking
about where you try to push down like
negative thinking with positive thoughts
instead of just kind of admitting to
yourself like I'm I'm actually dealing
with something kind of hard right now
instead of just admitting that to
yourself
like that would shine through in her
performance of using optimism to push it
away
that was excellent
stuff with the Bing Bong imaginary
friend you know like
that was heartbreaking to me of of like
because the imaginary friend scenario
you know
like to me I felt like growing up my am
I having an imagination was was such a
in that fantasy and escapism was such a
big part of my my survival is how I
would put it
and it's stayed with me my entire life
and you know you always hear the cliches
of like when you grow up you kind of
start rejecting that side of yourself
you stop being as playful
be an adult but I feel like we're all
we're all really just
all of us adults are really just
we're still our kids our childhood
selves just in a bigger form you know as
we reform from that like they call it
the core memories here and it's funny to
hear that because that's the word I
would use in my life is core memories
understanding core memories and core
memories so often help Define us and
what we ultimately develop into over
time
and
I loved I I loved the the uh the aspect
of the imagination is the thing that
helped find the the creative way like
Joy had to get creative to to pierce
through the again and then get to
sadness and to get to the headquarters
and it was that imagination that helped
save like because really this is all
Riley's mind and and the imagination of
that character is the one who
to help save the day is the imagination
side
so I thought that was really connected
with that and it was sad to see like
Bing Bong go away because it was
interesting with Bing Bong because he's
the kind of character where he was
amusing but I was like he might be a
little bit annoying
but then he wasn't I was worried he'd
get on my nerves
but he did it and then I felt I was
really affected by that moment when when
he ultimately did fade away to help Joy
get the chance to get to Edwards to take
care of Riley imagination helps saving
and and I think a lot of a lot of ways
it can it's not not like using fantasy
to become delusional towards your
reality
but there's the other side of it again
it's it's a gray area and I think what
this movie does is really help teach and
illustrate to embrace the gray area the
collectiveness the community of your
emotions versus just one way or the
other
and I think that's a powerful thing to
to say to adults and to kids and pretty
much everyone of all ages that's usually
what makes the best Pixar movies right
the ones that are for all ages
and uh yeah I thought it was great like
the way they dealt with dreams and the
reality Distortion of it and like yeah
that's that's what dreams feel like
reality distortion
and
you know I think dealing with the the
idea that you know uh
to keep up happy appearances and when
you're not maybe don't actually feel
happy and to be okay with letting you
know you don't feel like you have to let
everyone know but you can let some
people and on the ones who are most
important to you the ones you value if
you're most people doesn't give a [ __ ]
what's on everyone I'm sure go for it uh
but I think that's another great thing
to and still you know I live out in La
too where it was all over the world but
I really feel like in LA yeah it's
really hard for like
oh it has constant keeping up of
appearances out here can feel like a
facade after a while a charade so
yeah
and I'm going off the Dome here as I
always do but rather than picking apart
the plot points I feel like what I'm
talking about that is the plot points
and that's what I think makes for a
fascinating discussion about an animated
movie is these are the this is the plot
of the movie so and you're just watching
it play out in a in a way that's
digestible
for for families for children in a way
that can just they can be cute and fun
and a great Learning lesson but I think
it's also one of those movies I can
imagine watching this watching as a
little kid and then watching it like 10
years later and learning more like if I
saw us at five then understanding it
better at 15. and then wow 25 I could
understand it even way better 35 the
older you get the more you might be able
to actually understand this
so as much as I was like I feel bad like
I don't think me in 2015 would have even
understood this movie that well honestly
uh I might have been like yeah it's fine
but or like yeah I really appreciate but
uh who I am at 2015 in 2015 was is not
who I am today and anyway like I really
feel like I'm a very completely
different person from that so it's
it's just gnarly to see what they what
they put together here and I'm curious
what they do with the sequel because I
feel like there are many you'd have to
probably expand the emotions out
expanding characters out but there is a
lot you can do with a sequel that I'd be
very much interested in seeing because
you can go pretty mature too if you
really wanted to I hope the inside out
it's gone All PG-13 or R right here they
wouldn't do that there's a version where
obviously you could do that so I think
that would be crazy and the movie was
funny it was also like a really funny
movie if it was it found a lot of a lot
of great moments of of poignant humor as
well
and you know it is the kind of thing
where I feel like I just get more from
on a re-watch and and because it is a
it's a construct of the mind you know
even dealing with like long-term
memories and then if you don't nourish
those memories it can often fade away I
thought it was I thought that was great
I thought it was a really great film
with a with a really powerful narrative
uh as well so yeah
yeah I I loved it
um I wasn't expecting to talk about it
like this but here we are because that's
what the movie is at least my take but
guys uh what do you think about it I
thought the voice acting was great I
think the music of Michael giaccino
should have predicted it was him amazing
great Direction overall
and uh awesome voice over work
it was deep [ __ ]
and deep in a way they kept it
light-hearted for the for the most part
you know like it was really not a good
tone really strong tone might be one of
my favorite Pixar movies
alrighty well I'm done for the day thank
you for being here subscribe click that
Bell leave a like check with me on
patreon
[Music]